this is the Science of
Stupid
warning the following program has been
scientifically analyzed and found to
contain significant traces of
stupidity please do not attempt to copy
any of the dangerous acts you're about
to
see yes this is the show that extracts
scientific wisdom from Pure
stupidity take notes as people with too
much time and too little
sense test the boundaries of science
looking for
fun we'll reveal what went wrong and why
with the help of such key
principles as the coefficient of
friction animal defense mechanisms and
our old friend lift Force taunt science
and your tempting fate watch out it's
the Science of
Stupid in this episode we'll be taking
control of terminal velocity he was
okay looking closely at tire
traction and Diving head first into
propeller science but first
this it's hard to imagine anything more
terrifying than clinging death to a
sheer rock
face 40 ft up scrambling around for the
slightest hint of
[Music]
friction pretty
scary but not scary enough for some
climbers who like their Rock faces to be
somewhat
slippier the ice climber a rare breed
that scales gravity taunting ice
encrusted Cliff
faces and even frozen water
falls yeah just not for
me what makes ice climbing possible
aside from an inhuman head for Heights
and an enormous insurance premium is the
high strength of Ice's unique internal
structure but it does have its weak
points ice consists of water molecules
arranged hexagonally to form crystalline
structures this tightly organized
Arrangement can make an icicle strong
enough to support the weight of an ice
climber however as ice grows it can
create networks of weak Roots between
the
crystals these are more perilous near
the top of an icycle which Bears more of
its weight and so is under more stress
strike a weak point here and that
fracture can spread in an
instant okay before we grab our crampons
let's experiment with that unique
structure here we have a man
demonstrating how an ice shelf composed
of zillions of tiny hexagons is strong
enough to stand
on but not stamp on note how excessive
force appli by stamping results in
sudden fracture along weaker routes
between ice
crystals okay let's ice
climb here we
go close one still the ice did hold
strong there let's see how it does
further
[Music]
up me not great although the icicle did
kind of stay in one piece it's just that
it wasn't very well stuck to the grass
at the time
top you all right
Wallace okay Wallace but you do have to
pick your icicles
carefully and that is not an icicle I
would pick ice weighs nearly 60 lb per
cubic foot so that icle is already
supporting over a ton of its own
weight or at least it was remember the
higher you are the more stressed the
icicle and the more likely you are
to suffer a different kind of
stress and now we briefly avert our
gazes from people doing stuff wrong and
focus on someone doing something right
record-breaking right consider the
skydiver in freef Fall initially
accelerating to Earth At A terrifying
32.2 ft per second per second imagine
the relief when that parachute finally
pops open but what if they're not
wearing a
parachute like yasuhiro Kubo here going
for a Guinness World Record
title he'll be freef falling from around
10,000 ft and attempting to catch up
with his parachute attached to this
canister the record is determined by how
long he waits before
jumping at 50 seconds later off
[Music]
goes well that was a relief and a world
record Free Falling without a parachute
is one of the most dangerous stunts
imaginable do not even consider
considering to consider to do it
ever especially when even regular
skydivers have their off
days uh little help please
bro go on you can do it go on great
thank
you all right so how does a skydiver
fall fast enough to catch up with a
parachute thrown out nearly a minute
beforehand well to find out we need to
up on terminal velocity and air
resistance as an object falls it
collides with trillions of tiny air
molecules resulting in air
resistance as the object accelerates the
air resistance acting on it increases
until it matches the force of the
object's weight it's now at terminal
velocity the maximum speed it can
fall a larger surface area increases air
resistance and so decreases increases
terminal
velocity a smaller surface area
decreases air resistance and so
increases terminal
velocity a skydiver in spread eagled
position hits terminal velocity around
120 M an hour after about 12 seconds but
for yasuhiro to catch up with his shoot
that is just too slow so which of our
wanabe record Breakers has remembered
how we speed up our terminal
velocity
not these ones that is the complete
opposite their raft has a large surface
area thereby increasing air resistance
and slowing them
down okay anyone
else yeah that's it going upside down
and reducing his surface area decreases
air resistance and increases terminal
velocity trouble is
oh who it's very hard to control oh that
guy upside down
too yes he was once he's caught up with
his shoot yasu hero needed to steer
himself into position to grab it how did
he do that well skydivers can also use
air resistance to
[Music]
maneuver for example by adjusting his
body shape this guy deflects more air
backwards which pushes him
forwards
Bullseye somehow all of our High Flyers
were fine but I think we should leave
the record to
yasuhiro now can you guess what
scientific principle this freerunner is
about to
[Music]
demonstrate
did you work out the science he's about
to show
[Music]
us yes it's angular
momentum as he lands he pushes back with
his feet tipping the trash can this
rotates him around his Center of mass
giving him angular momentum he probably
didn't
want who says recycling can't be
[Music]
fun
in 1956 race car mechanic art Engles and
partner L barelli took an old lawnmower
engine and fashioned the very first
go-kart they got about two horsepower
out of it but go-karts aren't all about
straight line
speed races can be won and lost on the
curves sometimes with a little help
but when you've crossed the line seconds
ahead of the rest it's a moment to
treasure
selfie the secret to winning those
Corners lies in not losing too much
speed or traction and the secret to that
lies in straight lining a
curve our driver decelerates as he
approaches the corner Sweeping in from
wide and cutting across the apex of the
curve before accelerating out wide again
this is called straightlining a curve it
maximizes the radius of the curve he
follows allowing him to maintain a
higher speed with less risk of an under
steer where the front wheels lose
traction or an over steer where the back
wheels lose
[Music]
traction okay helmet's on and let's see
who can straight line a
curve well he
can beautifully Sweeping in from wide
tickling the Apex and accelerating out
wide again maximizing the radius and
protecting the lead another
one yeah not quite as good approach the
turn too tight and straight lining that
curve is going to be
hard so how about we take it a little
wider and yeah not that wide an over
steer causes his back tires to lose
traction a little corrective steering
later and now it's a massive under steer
two for
one okay we've got this find the line
maintain traction and he stolen the lead
now defending a corner means forcing
your attacker to take the worst possible
route yep that was a bad
one
as our driver Cuts in his attacker is
squeezed out and over steers
[Music]
significantly so it's like I said
go-karts aren't all about straight line
speed the path to Victory lies in
mastering the tightest of
turns but we can agree that is a little
too
tight
for thousands of years the key to
engineering strength has been down to a
simple
shape this
one from the 4,000-year-old Pyramids of
Giza to Dad's
bike well the frame anyway the triangle
has been recognized by Engineers as the
strongest of all polygons squares
rectangles pentagons nonagons decagons
no shape is in better shape than the
mighty
triangle apply Force to a square and you
can change its angles collapsing it even
if its sides don't
fail this is true of all polygons except
the
triangle no matter how much force is
applied a triangle will not collapse as
long as its sides don't fail systems of
triangles like trusses are particularly
effective at transferring loads to their
supports and squares and rectangles can
be reinforced simply by adding cross
braces which yep turn them into
triangles we owe the mighty triangle so
much because of it huge cranes can lift
1100 ton weights factories stadiums and
stations can bear vast roofs without
supporting
columns and the legs of this child swing
set can easily hold the weight of these
uh
[Music]
adults unlike the rotten Beam at the top
so how do you strengthen an entire
structure well trusses like these roof
supports are a system of connected
triangles that transfer the weight of
the roof to the walls this is either
going to work or it's not now I'm
hopeful because there is yet another
triangle making your ladder very
[Music]
sturdy see the ladder's completely fine
what that
hurt now rectangular structures like a
dresser can be reinforced by inserting a
cross brace to form
triangles this
[Music]
dresser yeah that's just a
rectangle so the force of the impact has
no trouble altering its
angles still it's much easier to pack up
now good work
guys but remember even a triangle is
only as strong as its
sides so as a tornado tears through
Russia even a Gantry crane that can
support hundreds of tons in
[Music]
weight has its
limits the inventor of the first out
board motor French electrical engineer
Gustav trou was also responsible for the
first electric vehicle the portable
electric safety lamp the endoscope and
the light up ballet dress in short the
man was a
genius but thanks to the Simplicity of
Gustav's outboard
motor you don't have to be a genius to
use one the outboard motor
distinguishable from the inboard in that
it sits outside the body of the boat can
be rigged to very small lightweight
boats giving them a high power to weight
ratio so with all that power in your
hands wouldn't it be good to understand
a little of the
science as propeller blades rotate they
accelerate a column of water backwards
producing a reaction force that thrusts
the boat
forward the propeller can be moved left
or right to
steer it can also be angled up called
trimming up which raises the bow
reducing Hydro Dynamic drag when at
speed for greater
efficiency or angle down called trimming
down which lowers the bow into the water
giving the hull more stability just
watch out for your
depth exactly how and when you alter the
direction of thrust through trimming is
a science in
itself trimming up raises the bow
reducing drag for efficient
planing or not yeah or
not when in a boat with a high power to
weight ratio it's best not to slam the
throttle on and
off okay on to steering and we're better
to learn than dingy derby practice where
boats can race up River at over 50 m an
hour and now for a textbook
180 ah I've not read that
textbook one dramatic change of thrust
Direction one massive increase of drag
at the
side leading to two wet
Sailors reverse propeller direction to
thrust backwards
nice trim up keeping that prop clear of
the bottom loving your work sir and to
finish a little showbo
it classic
drop your prop in extremely shallow
water and your boat may
stop but you might
not but once you've perfected thrust and
trim
control you can move on to more advanced
skills like
diving The Humble baseball more complex
than it looks comprising of an outer
layer of leather several layers of yarn
two types of rubber and a cushion cork
Center its mass gives it lots of
momentum okay lots of momentum not
always ideal so a safer option might be
this plastic Hollow lightweight it's
Kinder on your
furniture and Har L fun for
[Music]
kids but not for moms all right so
plastic balls not 100% painfree but with
whole tournaments across the US
dedicated to this variant of baseball a
few extra hours backyard batting for
junior could make a future star provided
they first complete their homework on
velocity momentum angles and
vortices some plastic balls are
perforated and spinning them can allow
air to rush into the hle
creating bises
inside that can curve the ball making it
harder to hit being hollow the ball also
has a lower Mass than a regular
baseball so he needs to strike with a
lot more velocity for it to gain
sufficient momentum and fly
far and striking underneath the ball so
it launches at around 25° also helps
maximized
distance therefore the ball's lower Mass
means they're safer for kids and
beginners and thanks to those internal
vortices curving the ball is Child's
Play you just have to know how to pitch
it this is not how to pitch it I'm not
going to try to hit you though I'm going
to go to
your
face with that excessive amount of
velocity and therefore
momentum they really didn't need to
bother with a
curveball because he didn't see that
coming
that's it nice fast swing plenty of
momentum but for distance you'd also
want to aim a little
higher yeah a bit higher than that
you're looking for that 25°
angle it was closer to minus
25° yeah that's more like it a high
velocity swing and an angle closer to
25° means even his hollow plastic ball
is heading for the stand now let's see
if we can launch it into next
[Music]
door oh yeah not
quite the achievements of Science in the
century alone are really quite amazing
we've detected water over 30 Million
Miles Away on Mars we've grown
functioning human organs and discovered
that 68% of our universe is composed of
a mysterious dark energy
but we're still not quite sure why
people do
[Music]
this
w